Congratulations, while it
may not seem like much,
you've gotten quite far already.
You learned how to connect user
interface element to the code
with IB actions, and use IB outlets
to change the state of UI elements
from the code within
your view controller.
You've also taken your first steps
into auto layout and, of course,
in developing for iOS using Swift.
Let's take a moment and discuss where
these UILabels and UIButtons come from.
In developing for iOS,
Apple wanted to make it easier for
us to create interactive elements.
To that end, much as it is on the Mac,
they've developed a series of frameworks
that we can use in building our iOS app.
The main framework you're going to
be using in this iOS development is
called UIkit.
Any classes that start with UI
are from the UIkit framework.
And these include UILabel, UIButton,
UIView, and even UIViewController.
We've not talked about
UIViewController as much yet, but
we're going to go into much
more detail in the next lesson.
There we'll provide
the logic behind a view and
what connects it to the model
which has all the data.
Sound familiar?
Yep, it's the model view controller
pattern we discussed earlier.
There are many many classes
inside the UIkit framework,
ranging from labels to buttons,
all the way to table views.
In addition to UIKit, there are many
other powerful frameworks in iOS,
from audio, to rendering,
to web services,
to even gathering data from the GPS,
gyroscope and accelerometer.
We're going to cover quite a lot
of them in this course and
give you a solid understanding and
practice in iOS development.
In the next lesson, we're going to take
Pitch Perfect and add multiple views.
We're going to set the groundwork so
it can record audio.